well since the pandemic pressed pause on  our local entertainment industry many  have pivoted to new career paths  we met one woman who traded the stage  for her real estate license  montes taylor was a performer with  cirque de soleil zumanity  but when the show shuttered back in  march she had to find something else to  support her family  that's when she turned to the real  estate business to find a new kind of  success  she says while it wasn't easy she'd  encourage others to take a similar leap  don't be afraid don't be scared i know  that  sometimes i'm a type a personality i  like to make sure that everything is  handled scheduled  out and these are things that you can't  predict and you just have to let someone  else take the rings and help you out  taylor was able to take courses and pass  her real estate test through a local  scholarship program with  schofield realty she says the local real  estate business is strong  and she's happy to have a steady income